gotcha ah better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News
you're watching slife on the show you
this week we're getting slowed safi the
breathtaking technology taking skiers to
new heights worst-case survival the
gadgets that could save your life and we
leave the real world for the virtual the
mounting bugs spread to this week's
games review too hello and welcome to
swipe from here the French Alps where
else would we go to film our ski tech
and mountain safety special here in the
resort of PCV laundry we've been getting
to grips with some of the latest
technology making life even better for
those who love snow sports here's Angela
technology is transforming the skiing
and boarding experience
from electronics key locating devices
that mean you'll never lose them again
to goggle designs enabling skiers to
capture their journey down the mountain
built-in HD cameras and Wi-Fi enabling
faster social media sharing and there
are goggles which let you locate and
text buddies on the piste listen to
music at the same time and track your
altitude and speed and there are phone
apps for that too check your not going
too fast get alerts for a change in the
weather and put a route down the slopes
using your phone's GPS but with all this
technology enhancing the user experience
on the slopes there are some concerns
that it could be compromising our safety
at the same time we as instructors
notice that the more technology that's
available and that people use people
become reliant on it and people refer to
it perhaps a little bit too much
particularly the issue of speed with
apps on phones and people putting a high
priority on skiing faster rather than
skiing safe level but there are some
safety hazards that you can't control
avalanches are a big worry especially
for those venturing off piste and this
is leading to increased innovation to
help save lives a transceiver is just
one of the pieces of kit getting smarter
enabling easier and more accurate
detection of a victim buried in snow I
mean I'm safety technology it's
improving each years because before
transceiver was a analogic ok and now
it's new numeric system so it you can
see what do you want a new transceiver
and it's easier for everybody to find to
find it somebody so it's definitely
easier than the old technology
electronic probes like this one can
reduce the search time for a victim and
jet fan air bags like the jet force
allowing multiple deployments are just
some of the designs increasing the
chances of surviving an avalanche but
local experts are also keen to remind
visitors unfamiliar with the terrain
that
technology can only help in some
scenarios and shouldn't be completely
relied on what is wrong technology has
really helped as a huge amount has given
us access to places we never dreamt we
could go to before and so much easier
the thing I think that one really must
remember is that the basic safety rules
have to always be here to you got to
really think about what's happening
around you listen to the advice look at
the Avalanche warnings and ideally
always just stay safe skiing peers never
go off on your own no matter how safe
you think you are without we have with
you so it's more gadgets take off and
transform mountain sports there's no
shortage of tech to enhance and capture
the experience and make it a safer one
at the same time Angela bands Sky News
well you saw an angeles piece there the
importance of staying safe on the
mountain with me now as well man who
lives dangerously but he knows how to
protect himself and others off piste ski
instructor Charlie Chadwick Tory thanks
for joining us now in terms of self
protection while you're skiing in
backcountry terrain what kind of
technology do you keep with you so
everyone including myself should have
the minimum which is a transceiver a
shovel and a probe okay and how do you
use this kind of kit so these these
transceivers like the one in my hand and
the one that I'm also wearing they send
and they search for radio waves okay so
anyone skiing off-piste could wear one
and then it's effectively tracking that
person yes so then if they were to
accidentally trigger an avalanche or
something awful like that would happen
then people can know how to find them
exactly safe if someone gets buried a
bit like the transceiver just over here
that one buried there okay so let's
pretend that someone who's out in to do
exactly so yeah fight if I turn this one
into search mode and this is the one
that picks it up now so something else
would have these exactly yeah so when
our getting a reading in meters so
saying 1.2 meters away it's pretty
accurate knows where we are yeah you
were then fine you'd be able to locate
that person in difficulty yeah and if
I'm lucky enough to have one of these
fancy new electronic probes yeah
everyone needs a standard probe anyway
but if you're lucky enough to have one
of these electronic
one's job is put together can switch on
then this will continue searching itself
as well so it will give me and that beep
does that mean that we're near to the
transceiver that this beat means we're
really close yeah ok so then at this
stage would you do with the probe so
this point i'll leave the probe in the
ground like sir it will stay that and
then i'll start digging find a victim
point where you dig yes a dangerous
sport what kind of tips would you give
to anyone who wants to do more awful so
the name the name of the game really is
to his experience so you want sir you
want as much training as you as you can
get really and ski with experience in
terms of avalanches I mean you must
trigger them off piskies trigger
avalanches yeah all the time when you're
skiing on steep terrain snow will be
moving and it's just how much snow moves
there's a big Avalanche better the
better training you have the more likely
you are to what be able to get by
without triggering an avidin yeah
knowing when and when not to ski things
okay yeah southbend dangerous Charlie
but thank you for talking to us thanks
Johnny us my pleasure i swipe your
watching swipe still to come things have
been pretty icy for us filming the show
this week but wait till you see what
lara croft been up to in our games
review stay with us but first here's a
roundup of some of this week's other
techniques a project to test driverless
cars launched in britain this week in
the hope the country will become a
leading global supplier it's thought
driverless vehicles could eventually
save motorists six working weeks a year
in driving time reduce congestion and
cut emissions alien isolation far cry 4
and Monument Valley lead the nominees
for this year's games BAFTAs alien
isolation based on the 1979 Ridley Scott
film has six nominations while the other
two titles have five each a lightweight
drone which can fly and bounced through
disaster areas will now move into
commercial production after winning
funding the developers of the collision
proof of liability gimbal beat off
competition from 19 other drones to win
the 606
thousand pound prize the drones for good
competition was organized by the United
Arab Emirates government well if you
can't make it to the soap this season
fear not there's plenty of wintry fun to
be had in the games that Lydia's picked
for us in this week's games review so
Lara Croft and the Temple of Osiris is a
sequel to Lara Croft and the garden of
light it's a spin off of the main series
tomb raider and it's a top-down co-op
puzzle game so you can play it with up
to three other players whether it be
online or sitting on the sofa next to
you and you work together as you explore
the Egyptian underworld now the DLC
called the icy death is it's a great way
of lining up the series because usually
we're used to that sandy sunny
atmosphere now everything's covered in a
lovely blanket of snow and ice and it's
been turned into this winter wonderland
it's really interesting because they
play with that with the puzzles which
you'll see the massive theme for this
game so they really incorporate that
element into it and it's just a really
nice take on this series that you can
play with your friends never alone is a
side-scrolling co-op puzzle game which
is set in Alaska so it's super snowy
it's very aesthetically pleasing it's
very charming it's lovely to play with a
friend so you play as you know the
little girl and her arctic fox friend
and you work together to get through
this great blizzard which is attacking
where you live so the interesting thing
about this game is there is a lovely
story behind it there is a tribe in
Alaska who wanted to talk more about
their folklore in the history so they've
done it wire the media of video games
the game is eight chapters long and at
the end of every chapter you get either
a video or information about their
history and things like that so it's a
real nice real learning experience as
well as a charming video game
well that's it for this week our time in
the Alps has come to an end is that we
will be back next week more swipe from
the UK and don't forget you can stay up
to date with all the latest tech stories
on Sky News for iPad or smartphone app
sky nice calm and a YouTube channel but
for now from here and all the lovely
people we met in pv for laundry comply
and sante better protect your bubble
calm proud sponsors of swype on Sky News